it's may 3rd 2022 so it's time for
another monthly update video in which
i'll talk about what went on in april
and what we've got coming up in this
month of may i always like to begin by
talking about three big things so big
thing number one on the 15th i'm going
to be using a new platform that i'm
trying out called light hall to offer a
free workshop anybody can come to
on five stoic practices from epictetuses
and caribbean it's gonna be a great
workshop so you know look at the the
link below and and you'll find i'll talk
more about that in the may section
big thing number two this is the
final semester for me teaching for
carthage college and i'm also no longer
teaching for milwaukee area technical
college i'm concentrating solely on
teaching for milwaukee institute of art
and design and on my own
stuff and we'll talk again more about
that in the month sections and this
leads to big thing number three
this month you can expect to see more
online classes that i have designed for
lifelong learners
students for personal enrichment coming
out so you can see those in the reason
io academy link to below
and you'll also see them in other
platforms as well
so those are the big things let's talk
now about april
april was a tough month for me and i
didn't get anywhere near as much
accomplished as i would have liked
and you know i think if you've been
following me on social media you know
about a good bit of that some of it was
the natural end of semester stuff that's
going on and students right now are very
burnt out very much sort of dragging
themselves to the end but we had two
other big things happen in april
one of them was that our 19 year old cat
sassy who i was very close to my wife
was as well she raised her from a kitten
along with her sister
sassy died and that was about midway
through the month and
that was a real kick in the guts
so you know i ended up
postponing some events and meetings due
to that and then
i got a double whammy because
i got sick and we later found out
through testing that i was sick with
covid there's a lot of people getting
what we call a breakthrough covid you
know you're triple vaxxed you've been
careful this entire time you haven't had
kovid and because everybody's you know
unmasking everywhere
it's easier to get get
covered and i thought it was allergies
at first and then eventually
we
prudently did a cove head test and by
that point i was actually quite sick
so that entailed um canceling a lot of
things as well so
april was not the most productive month
for me um
i did actually hold one of the stoic
sunday sessions on the virtue of wisdom
that video is linked to
below and i'll talk about you know the
other ones coming up uh in in may as
well we did have a um
heavy metal
classic metal class with me the heavy
metal philosopher my good friend scott
truly as well from berkeley school of
music and we talked about
classic metal power ballads which was a
really fun thing i did one of my half
hour hegel sessions i held an ama
and i also did a presentation last week
which
kind of wore me out for the dionysus
circle
which is a new organization devoted to
neoplatonic philosophy and i presented
on and some of canterbury and divine
simplicity
and the trinity everything else i put
off till this month
video work i
i got one half hour hegel video shot and
out there for my half hour hegel patreon
supporters i released some other half
hour hegel videos that i had shot the
previous month
i did quite a few core concept videos
for my medieval philosophy students on
alkoen's
cool work on virtues and vices
and on anselm of canterbury's on truth
and i also did one wombo video where i
took you know the images that were
generated from taking my dissertation
title or at least as much of it as we we
could get into it catholicism
modernism modernity the concrete logic
the philosophy of insufficiency and then
it's dot dot dot and you know so that's
kind of cool that's linked to below
and i did you know my ama video which
you can see
and the stoic sunday um event on on
the virtue of wisdom
that's recorded as well
so you know not a ton of video
production compared to previous months
but but enough
and then uh the podcast i actually did a
vote about which authors we should do
in which order
so some of them i've already um done the
the the podcast for and released the the
immanuel kant groundwork for the
metaphysics of morals started on
aristotle's nick mccain ethics book five
and then um before that i'd also done
some stuff on foucause the subject and
power and on george dickey's art and
anti-art or and what is art and then i i
was finishing up with cicero's on the
ends book three
so i did a lot of you know podcast work
this month and you know it's been kind
of a like i said a tough month
by the way not looking for any advice
about covid or grieving or anything like
that we got that handled
and you know we're just kind of moving
on slowly from from that into the next
month
we have a rather ambitious set of events
set up for may ambitious since i'm still
you know dealing with covid which could
derail things hopefully i'm gonna just
keep getting better and better but you
know we'll see how things go so all the
times i'm going to give for this are
central time you want to make sure you
you check your time zone if you want to
participate everything that i'm going to
narrate here is also online so everybody
can join in if they want to anywhere in
the world
starting on the 7th the saturday coming
up
at noon central time i'll have my
monthly ama that's ask me anything
session we'll go for about an hour and a
half you probably want to get your
questions in early in the session
because i never get to all of them some
people get a little bit miffed that they
don't get their their question gotten to
but you know i try to handle as many as
i can
then that same day a little bit later on
for my patreon supporters
i'll have my
monthly philosophy chat that's a little
bit more intimate setting talking about
philosophy and video conferencing on the
8th the next day at noon we will have
the next basics of stoicism a stoic
sunday
live streaming event and i'll be talking
about the virtue of justice which is
absolutely important for stoics and you
know what does it comprise what does it
include
on the 11th
at 5 pm we'll have our public half hour
hegel q a and discussion session that's
open to anybody it's underwritten by the
supporters of the half hour hegel
project
on the 14th
at noon and also at 1 30 p.m we'll have
the next worlds of speculative fiction
session which is going to be on olaf
stapleton and his cosmic novels
the first and last men
star maker i'm also reading through his
lectures on ethics which is quite
interesting so i'll do a video premiere
first then we'll have live chat with
that and then we'll follow that up with
a
video conferencing for those who are
particularly interested in that
on the 15th the thing one of the three
big things that i talked about for this
month we're going to have this workshop
hosted on light hall a new
platform that looks quite robust and
quite interesting we're trying it out
free workshop on five stoic practices
that you can use to improve your life
taken from epictetus's and caridian it's
a 90-minute workshop
pretty valuable but i'm i'm making it
free for everybody so we can see how
this actually works and how how good of
a platform it is so
the link for that is below i'll probably
do a video about that as well inviting
people to it
on the 21st uh scott truly and i are
doing classic metal class and this time
the topic
is going to be reviewing
recent that is from 2018 to 2022
recent albums by classic metal bands so
bands that had their origin in the 70s
and the 80s so this will include for
example you know saxon's new album and
iron maiden's new album and you know
tokyo blade's new album and a bunch of
other ones as well so that should be
quite interesting and we'll probably
need more than one session to to do that
scott and i were just talking about it
earlier today and it's going to be a
really fun session
on the 22nd that sunday we'll have the
next stoic sunday basics of of stoicism
and this time we'll focus on the virtue
of courage so we've got two of these
stoic sundays coming up this month
and then finally on the 26th at 6 pm we
have our milwaukee stoic fellowship we
are focusing on
diogenes lierte's summary of stoic
doctrine found in his lives of the
philosophers
and we're looking at some of the
discussions about ethics so those are
all the events coming up this month
what else do we have going on you know
i'm doing a lot of
writing so you know if you look at my
medium you'll see stuff coming out if
you don't know about my medium you
probably want to go and check it out
because that's where i do my popular
writing we've got a lot of cool things
lined up in stoicism today the the blog
for modern stoicism i'm doing some
academic writing as well and some
collaborative stuff
i've got a lot of client meetings lined
up with my tutorial
and uh consulting and philosophical
counseling clients
and i'll probably i imagine have a few
new ones trickling in as well
i'm going to be doing a lot of video
work this month hopefully i've started
doing some remastering of those
those old epictetus
and caridian videos
that i did back in stoic week i want to
say
what
2016 or 2017 i'm fixing the sound and
making them a bit better and
re-uploading them
i'm going to do some more half-hour
hegel videos we're getting close to the
end
uh you can expect to see a tribute video
about sassy the cat
um
it'll be pretty long
compared to the ones on teensy and the
two dogs uh in park because she lived
longer and i've got more video footage
about her and you know she she probably
was the animal that i bonded most in my
life the most closely with ever in in my
lifetime so there's a lot to say i got a
lot of book review videos i want to do
as well um been meaning to get to those
for a while now that the semester is
almost over
we'll be able to to do a lot of those
and you know some core concept videos
i'm definitely going to do some on
abelard and eloise and their letters
back and forth to each other
i might do some on saint bernard and his
treatise on love of god
we'll see if i can get to those
and then i'll probably do a few more of
those asides digressions and rants
from the hegel footage that i have
because people seem to like them and as
it turns out going back through the
footage
i do actually engage in quite a few
rants and digressions from time to time
so that might be kind of interesting to
to do
i'm also going to be doing some
podcasting as usual and continuing on
with the aristotle nick mccain ethics
book 5 stuff then it's augustine
some stuff from the city of god that i
didn't get to before and then we'll do
some epictetus but in there
on the way we're also going to do
um three prudentius
uh podcast uh episodes on the
psychomachia i'll be releasing those
early as a matter of fact later today to
my patreon supporters who will get a you
know sneak peek at those and then i'll
release them to the general public later
on
down the line you know so if you want to
see them uh become a patreon supporter
and you'll you'll get a early release of
those there's other stuff that i do
that's kind of cool on patreon as well
so
a lot of stuff that happened in april
a lot of stuff coming up in may as you
can tell my voice is about to give out
so i'm going to just say i hope you all
have a great month and i hope to see you
in some of these online events
particularly the
the experimental one the free workshop
on five stoic practices and epictetus is
in caridian i hope that we get a lot of
people
coming in for that because i think that
could be quite useful for
a lot of people's lives and a great
introduction to stoic philosophy if you
don't already know something about it so
have a great month and i will see you
somewhere in the ether
you